bonjour georgie richaud bonjour aux
auditeurs de martinique 1ère secrétaire
général du parti communiste martiniquais
soutien à jean-luc mélenchon et safran
s'est soumise pour la présidentielle de
la fin du mois on y reviendra dans
quelques secondes
peut-être d'abord une réaction ce qui se
passe sur le plan social en martinique
les transporteurs qui demandent cette
des taxes supplémentaires concernant
leur en but rang manifestement vous ne
comprenez pas ce mouvement georget
richaud non je crois que les
transporteurs se trompent
d'interlocuteur dû s'inspirer de ce qui
sera sans doute se tourner vers l'état
et non pas vu à la collectivité
territoriale de martinique qui a déjà
fait un effort considérable puisque la
détaxe cdu en martinique ses 2200 ou
déjà pour un camion alors qu'un bus n y
en a pas à la réunion
ce quelque chose comme 6 600 ou 400
euros en guadeloupe pareil le qui a déjà
un effort considérable qui est déjà fait
pour la cité m et vu je comprends le
brésil demain je pense que la situation
financier est extrêmement difficile et
on ne peut pas prendre ne peut pas
promettre qu'on aura ce qu'on n'a pas
ils sont hors sujet selon vous je ne dis
pas qu'ils en tout cas ici ont transité
au locuteur le candidat que vous
soutenez jean luc mélenchon a plutôt le
vent en poupe on va dire mieux il est en
plein boom
il serait selon certaines estimations
dans les intentions de vote en quatrième
position
jean luc mélenchon à un point de
françois fillon c'est merveilleux c'est
fantastique c'est inespéré pour vous ce
n'est pas inconditionnel
il est déjà bien en avance par rapport à
mon et maintenant il a clairement dit
que l'objectif c'est françois fillon et
il n'est pas impossible qu'il y
parvienne vu le dynamisme de sa campagne
comment expliquer justement n'y a pas
que le seul dynamisme de sa campagne a
paraît-il ses talents d'orateur un
éditorialiste de la radio rtl estime que
sa maîtrise des mots la richesse de son
vocabulaire permet cette percée dans un
pays où le verbe où le verbe compte
beaucoup
ah oui mais il est il est tous les
analystes
le présente comme le meilleur orateur de
la campagne mais ce n'est pas suffisant
je crois qu'il a une présence heures
c'est vrai lors de ses interventions l'a
vu l'horreur du débat sur je crois tf1
on l'a vu lorsqu'il a rassemblé à la
défense soit la république
environ cent trente mille personnes 130
personnes démonstration de force et
c'est un homme qui joue t il au dessus
des autres
d'abord de pas son image d'honnêteté un
qui est un argument qui a donné le mot
qui revient très fort maintenant la
campagne à une très forte exigence
d'honnêteté de la part des électeurs
d'où les difficultés notamment de deux
filles ont exemple mais aussi il s'est
construit une figure une image rassure
et où dit pas on le prenait pour le mais
d'un champ bouillon bouillon notamment
2012 et à mesure qu'il monte dans les
sondages son tour deviennent de plus en
plus doux en fait ils ruinent lui ce
prix qu'ils recèlent résidentialisés oui
il se précise bon ce n'est plus
simplement un simple troublions un nom
il a une image de présidentiable savez
ce que dit madame rossignol laurence
rossignol ministre de la famille elle
estime que jean luc mélenchon s'adresse
aux français comme quelqu'un qui ne va
pas gouverner et qui se place plutôt
dans une posture d'opposition à écouter
et c'est vrai que son mouvement
s'appelle bien
la fosse est soumise mais il a déjà
dépassé ce stade la hat a calé son
objectif
son objectif il indiqué au mois c'est de
faire la liaison entre la france et des
six parce nous ne faut pas oublier qu'il
ya eu plus de 35% des électeurs qui
n'ont pas l'intention d'aller voter
donc il veut faire la liaison soit la
france est soumise et la fois indécise
la france a dit comment il va faire
c'est dans son programme qu'il faut
aller chercher ce qui nous amène à dire
interdire par exemple les licenciements
grâce à sa méthode
vous savez que et il a investi les
réseaux sociaux ouais c'est le plus
dynamique sur les réseaux sociaux il ya
une télévision qui c'est qui qui
fonctionne sur youtube et cetera
maintenant il a des arguments qui
commence à frapper un adversaire résolu
de la loi est comme lui la loi travail
et dans son programme il entend
interdire les licenciements boursiers on
a vu les ravages que cela on va définir
le licenciement boursier lorsqu'une
entreprise gagne beaucoup d'argent
énormément d'armes et d'argent qui
licencient malgré tout ça ce sera fini
sur ce cas interdit il existe ainsi
pourquoi notre proposition c'est
pourquoi si vous sauvegardez ou
augmenter les profits des actionnaires
ça ne veut pas dire que l'entreprise
n'est pas rentable
il est simplement parce que les
actionner en demande toujours plus
toujours plus alors lui je croque
d'autant plus que certaines de ces
propositions essentielles ont bénéficié
du séisme vous savez il ya 31 milliards
d'euros qui sont messieurs jusqu'en 2017
2018 à disposition des entreprises aux
motifs sauvegarde des emplois rappelez
vous qu'à gattaz avait pour améliorer un
million d'emplois avait prétendu
nationale et brochets ou alors on
licencie à tire larigot et que par
conséquent et cécile appelait il ya ces
cent fleurs fais ce qu'il te plaît ce
discours-là pleure je crois que
maintenant
de toute façon les sondages de chandails
de bv a dit que 44% des français ne sais
pas si vous l'avez 44% des fossettes
disent que de tous les candidats il ya
celui que vous présente le plus la
gauche la gauche véritable épicerie pas
gagnant un peu je ne sais pas s'il va
gagner je souhaite reagan
mais en tout cas il ya le dynamo de
mélenchon qu'on ne prenez pas au sérieux
au début et qui maintenant s'impose dans
la campagne
et vu le pourcentage d'indécis vu par
exemple points dans le cas de mâcon il
n'y a pas de 30% de son électorat qui
est encore flottant de ceux qui se
disent ans à aller voter polluer mais
dans les idées positionnement n'est pas
évident et pourtant ils caracolent en
tête de ces attentions devrait
normalement il ne manque plus parce
qu'il représente ce fameux
renouvellement demandé par en 1975
jusqu'à aussi symboliser le président en
a pour dix ans peut-être une image est
cité c'était d'anti de gaulle voyez pas
eh bien je crois que le jury soit 54%
des fausses a dit ce qu'il ya c'est lui
mme lise lemieux des aspirations de la
classe ouvrière et de la gauche et que
par exemple il ya une marge
la marge est extraordinaire et et même
paraît-il
parce que dans une hutte d'un dans l'ue
on ne distingue pas d'après lui des
bulletins de vote même paraît-il y
adhéreront à droite qui sont censés
voter pour lui parce qu'ils ne croient
plus en fillon soit parce que le
programme filles on y va récupérer tu en
perds je suis musicien aime selon vous
je sais tout l'erreur je ne sais pas
s'il va récupérer le tout mais pour
l'instant et les bâtisses large alors
j'ai ri cho de parler nouveau très
sincèrement par une autre et franchement
pourquoi selon vous emmanuel macron
serait une escroquerie
à écouter parce que quand vous poignet
les gens du surréalisme date d'avant
quand vous prenez là l'éventail des gens
qui se sont ralliés l'arche de noé
gilardino vous avez déjà le doigt
vous avez des jt socialiste vous avez
même d'anciens comme un hobby ou par
exemple vous avez des gens des radicaux
de gauche
vous avez des gens comment pouvez-vous
avec quelle majorité parce que les
jeunes fois élus les gens pour autre
chose comme ça c'est dur est déjà de
gagner mais normes quoi l'essentiel
c'est de gagner ce oui oui oui mais il
faut parfois ces sables faut que les
marques et qu'elles savent si quelqu'un
dit d'alice et quelle serait la cause de
la politique tu m'amènes après pour ce
qui est des élections élections
législatives est aussi important que
l'élection présidentielle parce que la
constitution de la vème république telle
qu'elle est faite et bien les fêtes pour
composite ne disposent pas ou si c'est
bien le show aurait plus de cartes en
main que macron s'il arrivait là je
crois qu'il est en tout cas il est
capable de fédérer puce ans qui
s'abatterait pas qu'il ne serait pas
capable de le faire parce que
véritablement véritablement sa majorité
était tombée au kit était au clic et et
vous allez voir et la mise en
application de ce programme
enfin soulevé des oppositions féroce
parce que lui il n'est pas il n'est pas
il c'est à dire si anti système
mais ma foi n'est pas anti système pas
du tout il va conserver le même système
et ne va pas lutter contre les
licenciements boursiers
ils ne il ne va pas lutter contre les
paradis fiscaux
toutes choses comme la chanson propose
de faire et que par conséquent il
pourra pas mener une politique répondant
aux aspirations des travailleurs
et pourtant il plaît et pourtant il est
séduit pourtant il rallie de monsieur
moi je ne compare pas
macron à hitler mais cela est arrivé au
pouvoir des mots démocratiquement il
faut se méfier et puis il ya les médias
qui pousse et il ya les médias suppose
qu'ils pensent d'un système dans le
système et vous savez des médias façon
contrôlée par les grands groupes
financiers ce n'est pas à vous que je
vais d'apprendre ça et que par
conséquent lui c'est pourquoi mais la
shoah et l'intelligence de contourner
ces gros médias et ça fonctionne
ils s'affrontaient alors là on entre de
parler d'une éventuelle numéro deux au
second tour qui de macron qui de fillion
qui de mélenchon face à marine le pen
marine le pen à qui elle est tout le
monde dit qu'elle sera au deuxième tour
oui mais elles sont douzièmes tout c'est
vrai parce qu'elle a un socle électoral
bon équipe résister à dit comme ça et
puis dès que les sanitaires bon c'est
peut-être ma original mais en tout cas
je ne crois pas sincèrement comment une
le pen puisse accéder au pouvoir en face
je ne crois pas parce que son programme
qui est fondamentalement anti libérale
mais vient mon mari
marine le pen pas démagogie au point des
arguments de la cgt pour dire qu'elle
est aussi un bon maintenir la retraite à
60 ans avec 40 annuités que mais
fondamentalement le pen ne va pas
s'attaquer aux puissants dangereux et ne
va pas s'attaquer au patronat et ne tend
pas lutter contre la fraude fiscale elle
même elle a subi un nouveau coup elle se
méfie beaucoup de l'union européenne
tout comme certains jean luc mélenchon
oui mais pas que jamais mais pas pour
les mêmes raisons pas pour les mêmes
raisons mais la chaux 10 1 1
je vais négocier des traités ce duo mais
tout le monde reconnaît que les beaucoup
de traiter comme le pacte de stabilité
financière par exemple et et puis de
démocratie en europe
en 2005 par exemple les poissons rejeté
le traité constitutionnel
54% et mich mélange pas je le rappelle
était à la tête de la campagne contre le
traité constitutionnel
des fois si l on doit jeter et houle et
c'est presque fini et ayez ceux qui sont
venus
eh bien ils l'ont approuvé merci d'avoir
été avec nous georges erichot ses
anciennes convaincu à jean luc mélenchon
de la france est soumise merci d'être
venu avec nous mais redonne vécu merci
[Musique]